that's something i would do to you i
know you that's what i'm going to do
please bro i've got nowhere else please
you'd agree and then i would mug you up
oh my god
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
please you're messing with me please
sorry for
[Music]
while going guys happy monday what's
good people
you chilling here with your boys j money
fired for eggs you already know what it
is we've been around the block a few
times now we're getting familiar we're
friends now we're boys when you must see
us on road you come say hello there's no
fear there's no anxiety you just jump in
because you know we're cool we're cool
peeps um
and because we're cool
we're going to give you some extra
service so what you need to do is pause
the episode right now head on over to
patreon.com forward slash shits and gigs
and
treat yourself treat yourself
literally is a true treat yourself we
all deserve a treat now and again treat
yourself and head on over there and uh
enjoy an extra episode every thursday
every single thursday without fail
you're going to get an extra episode and
it's only going to cost you three pound
a month 10p a day run the p you already
know what it is you've got two years
worth of content to catch up on and then
once you're all caught up
every thursday guys
enjoy enjoy enjoy enjoy um
and we we get deeper on a lot of show
recommendations film reviews uh pick
your poison there's a lot of patreon
exclusive stuff that we do over there
first choice on ahmad the arsehole's
friends there you go all the messages
get responded to asap first choice on
everything and uh guys there's a good
time over there there is actually
there's strong chirps in the comments
over there there is all these strong
chapters i've seen guys comment on there
today
man commented saying like some happy
birthday thing
and then at the bottom i had a thing
that had already
um commented below him which was some
that those love heart eyes oh
that's chaps and compliment at the same
time
yeah people on patreon know what it is
breeding grounds breeding grounds
working um
on top of that guys if you are listening
on spotify apple podcast google podcast
wherever you listen to your podcast
please for the love of god leave a nice
review for us um for the others who
don't understand a star rating system
five is the best and one is the worst i
checked one on there the other day i
went because i get an email every time
not every time people leave reviews but
once a week i get this like weird
roundoff email and all the people that
have left reviews on there you can see
them on there which is really cool
they're anonymous but it doesn't matter
um
and one person
left this like [ __ ] paragraph like a
paragraph of just pure compliments
and they wrote us one stop
ah
bare compliments in this huge paragraph
and they rated it one star i was
thinking brother oh you're kidding me
here one star one star that's there you
you
you've literally just caused a dip in
the in the flux in the ether yeah yeah
ten thousand people didn't hear us
because of that one stuff
that's what if i saw that i thought he
smelled like dead
um but anyway guys so yeah please leave
uh a review five stars is nice but if
you do truly think we just have one star
then [ __ ] it just anything helps yeah um
if you are watching on youtube we're
doing bits on youtube it's mission 100k
we won that plaque soon come soon come
yeah uh we're getting there um i think
we're around
75 80k at the minute um so yeah whatever
we're on the way there guys so please
subscribe please like the video if you
liked the video and as always guys
chirps atting in the comments it's
important if we're going to head over if
to the breeding grounds to the log cabin
white robes and yeezys and take this
cult to a national level
uh international level if you will
for generations to come we're going to
need the funds and we're going to need
the growth and we're going to need
breeding ground so in order to create
the breeding grounds we need you lot to
chirp each other in the comments
so once you meet it smacks it yeah
once you meet honestly
yeah
the small talk yeah less of that yeah
yeah with three layers deep yes
physical interaction laughs and physical
interaction that's all we need yeah man
yeah man yeah man so guys kept singing a
comment subscribe um and like the video
if you like the video thank you very
very much
um but yeah without any further ado
let's head on over to firelord fuegs for
his fun fact on this freaking fun
fun day
right caption baby born with two penises
has the larger one surgically i
literally saw this today i saw it today
the largest one removed
from
when he's of age yeah
find me the doctor
when they tell me the story find me let
me read the thing i will re-enact all
right say let's say
a brazilian boy who was born with two
penises has ended up having the his
bigger member chopped off
doctors operate on a younger boy on a
young boy sorry after they discovered he
after they discovered his two appendages
were conjoined at the base
in a one in five million birth defect
wow
medics were originally planning on
chopping off the smaller johnson
brackets which many would think would
have been the obvious move
however they changed their mind finding
out a bit more crucial information
the boy's mother revealed her son can
only urinate from the smaller penis
examinations show that his left penis
the bigger of the two couldn't function
correctly and the boy's urethra was too
narrow for urine to pass through
so they had to lop off the big one
question
hit me if it was you
yeah if i was the you or the doctor if
you were the you yeah and you understood
let's just say you understood the like
how imperative it is to have a big dick
yeah and the doctor as a you i know this
is a yeah okay yeah so um
but
they said look
we can chop off
the uh we can walk we can chop off the
small thing and you're gonna have let's
just say they can guarantee it's gonna
be a fat dick
a [ __ ] big dick dave what's the word
when they see that they're futurecast
yeah yes
they've done some future casters and
they thought oh this one's gonna look
like it's sweating yeah it's gonna be a
yummy tall it's not even they think it's
gonna be perfect it's not gonna be too
big yeah yeah it's not gonna be
grotesque yeah it's gonna be it's going
to be it's going to be a locker yeah you
look like you pull it down like oh it's
a hammer yeah yeah it's a war hammer
literally
and it's it's big soft as well
that's what i'm saying is this is it
it's a grower and a shower you're gonna
have a hammer on you yeah say less
but you're gonna have to have like we're
gonna have to install like a permanent
catheter because you can't piss out of
it yeah you can not have it and
everything else feels the same but you
can't piss so you're gonna we're gonna
have to put a permanent catheter in you
you're um
so you're gonna have like a bag here
that you just piss
permanently and obviously if you want a
nut if you want to beat whatever you can
just dash the bag hope you don't piss
but you're gonna have a dick on you or
you're gonna have this little baby thing
okay what but you can piss like a man
what are the inches i need any sizes so
the big thing is how big i don't know
this is the way thing with me right
everyone seems to know inches i don't
[ __ ] know i don't know what inches i
i know what inches are obviously but i
don't know i don't know how many inches
my dick is i can't see a dick like i
always hear stories of women turn
stories about oh i saw this guy's dick
like it must have been like three inches
hard and i'm like how do you know
what reference well we had this
discussion before though no it must be
due to dildos oh yeah true
yeah but there's never it's not a
three-inch dildo i refuse to believe
yeah what there might be like a
three-inch like bullet or rabbit or
whatever yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you wouldn't know it's
three inches you just buy it well yeah
i'm sure i'd like to assume they have
the sizes on the thing yeah but what i'm
saying is like
in my opinion from a marketing
perspective
like a bullet or rabbit it's not going
inside you
that's a vibration yeah yeah okay so
there's no reason for that to have
inches on there i don't know dildo yeah
yeah there's reason to have inches on
there because you think i want a 10 inch
i want an eight inch a three incher they
can't be selling that they can't be
selling that
they've got stock of stock or stuff
anyway i don't know right let's what's a
good sized dick like seven eight inches
let's let's go seven eight seven right
okay cool so let's say the big dick is
like a nine incher
okay maybe ten i don't know that's too
big i don't know that's that's
too big i feel like that's massive all
right um
let's okay cool i feel like that's
uncomfortably massive all right let's
say the big dick is like a at eight and
a half incher i feel like that's all
good yeah it's a war hammer
um
and the small ones like a two incher
like you can't [ __ ] worth a damn two
inch are hard
or too much of [ __ ] it's a two inch of
showing and a three and a half incher
heart wow yeah yeah
so is either have that for the rest of
my life when it gets hard it's proud
like it's like it like it's pinging it
wiggles
with joy
the slit the helmet here but it gets
hard like
the helmet yeah
[Music]
yeah um so it's either three and a half
inches hard
or is that eight is that hard or is that
soft the eight
the eight and a half is hard eight and a
half hard but it's it's still like seven
soft seven
seven soft eight and a half hard yeah
for the biggen
but i've always got a catheter strapped
towards me 24 7. unless i want to have
sex and i take it off you've got a
pissed bag on you
[ __ ]
or two inches soft three and a half hard
but you can piss a comparison you've got
just no issues no issues whatsoever
i might have to go for the catheter you
know yeah yeah because
even though
i'd like to believe
women not don't necessarily think size
is everything they do but yeah i know
they do but sometimes they don't as well
they like they like the you know [ __ ]
like that but there's nothing i can do
with three and a half yeah i mean i know
what you mean like
so yeah you can have like a good sized
dick and they're not like i wish it was
good but i wish it was ten exactly yeah
okay i get you i get you but there's
literally nothing i can do with three
and a half no you can't do anything like
you're using yes it goes in yes she may
feel a sensation yes i will definitely
feel a sensation yeah
but it's it's it's just there's no
equilibrium to that do you know what i
mean so it's gonna have to be i'm just
gonna have to have a piss back i'm gonna
have to have a piss bag
and that that upsets me yeah bro
that upsets me bro yeah bro oh
oh that's tough
it's not fair it's really not fair
dead dog i hope yeah i just hope this
smaller dick grows to be
satin yeah
it's a little brazilian yeah
yeah yeah but it's a little brazilian
you i don't know why that's funny
because boy
that's
harsh because imagine if you had like
imagine if that this the small thing is
actually [ __ ] small
[ __ ] small
and he grows up and he's like
why did they drop off the bigger one all
right
do you think you'd notice something was
wrong because obviously as a you or as a
baby when they're doing the surgery
whatever you have no idea but honestly
honestly it's only when you grow up and
you start pissing yourself and blah blah
blah you would actually start holding
your dick and actually pissing him one
more you know do you think you'd one do
you think you'd notice that there was
something there it used to be another
day it used to be some you weren't you
wouldn't know you wouldn't i don't think
you'd necessarily think there was
another dick there but you think what
the [ __ ] is this scar you know probably
yeah i reckon so but i don't i don't i
don't really know what the anatomy looks
like like is it two completely separate
dicks coming out of the base or is it
like one dick and then just like another
dick or it's like it must be too
fully
in order for them to chop one off i
doubt it's one dick attached to another
no no i i i'd like to assume it's two
completely different separate entities
yeah but
two balls as well
yeah one set of balls one set of balls
and two actually fully formed dicks yeah
like one whether you but only one
urethra yeah
yeah you'd see the scar but if they're
doing a good job i don't think
because if there's no piss hot if
there's no like
hmm
yeah if there's no like piss oil or if
there's no connection to like your blood
or whatever
i don't think
the scar will be that big
so let's say you're like
10 11 or whatever and your mom sits you
down and your pop sits you down and
explains you story how would you feel
you were born with two dicks you were
born with two dicks they had to lop off
the bigger yeah one was actually
alarmingly big it was frightening
like i looked at your talk and i looked
at your dad and think for
yo
yeah is it yours this doesn't add up
yeah
one was like
a healthy dick
it made newspapers the fact the fact
that we had to lock it up
and your dick is the other one
how would you feel
uh i'd have to yeah if i'm a teenager by
this point i'd have to be like why the
[ __ ] did you get rid of the big one
and they're like because you couldn't
piss out of it
and blow what let me make that choice
what were my options
what were my options
you would have had to have some bag it
wouldn't have been
take it
take it because i [ __ ] three girls and
all of them laughed me out of bed
they laughed me out mum mum they laughed
me
are you proud
no because even if i had the pissed back
as soon as they see that fat veiny dick
they don't care i don't care if i don't
care anymore you look at me little pissy
boy
you little pissy boy
they don't care about that because i'm a
man
[Laughter]
but
with a little dick
yeah you're not you could be the
penguins guy in the world bro a three
and a half solid
wow it looks like that um do you ever
see those those door stops with the
spring
denting i could never have that i could
never have that for you
sorry to guys out there
literally listening
bro there's there are couples are
listening to this right now there's no
such girl signing looking at a man
knowing he's got three three and a half
injured
and the guy is facing forward he doesn't
have time to entertain his confidence
he's saying let's watch something else
let's listen to something else let's
watch something else because these men
are baiting me out right
and i'm tired of it
three and a halfs i'm sorry guys i'm so
so sorry i had to be you i no i actually
am though because it's not fair that's
the one thing where it's just like
that's not fair but i was gonna say
there's nothing to do about i'm sure
pretty sure there's stuff you can do but
you get like penis enlargement
yeah if i had a tiny tiny dick i promise
you yeah yeah yes yeah but do you
obviously it's not something i've
searched so i don't even know what the
repercussions are but
would you even care about the repo no
that's yeah so i'm saying i'm saying yes
with chess not also not knowing what the
reaper i don't care what the
repercussions are help me
help me i can't form a strong
relationship i'm constantly paranoid
that my hope's gonna cheat on me
i can't trust
i can't love i can't be loved back
sex isn't an embarrassment for me
damn
i've never seen a girl come ever in my
life so you'll never be able to make her
come
to be fair actually like yeah thicker
side yeah
tongue and fingers yeah
she wants the motion
she wants the motion yeah
oh that's depressing yeah sorry guys
three and a half years i'm so sorry and
the ladies with the three and a halfers
that was the choice you made that to be
fair that's the choice that's the choice
you made
hold that over your head don't you dare
hold that over here because you chose to
be here
don't you [ __ ] dare
that's hilarious anyway
you had a fan request no
yes i do uh let me see if i can squander
it right guys uh fan request
um hi guys big fan from brooklyn
i've only just discovered you guys so
i'm not sure you've discussed this topic
before
so i'm yeah so in a couple of weeks it
will be a year since me male 25 and my
ex female 26 broke up
we were together for just over three
years and honestly she's the love of my
life
i was planning on proposing by the end
of summer 2021.
since then we fooled around for a bit
and we're talking about getting back
together but we never quite got there
fast forward to january 2022 she told me
that she started dating a new guy
needless needless to say i was
heartbroken
we still talk regularly and i even just
had easter dinner with her and her
parents
i'm super i'm super conflicted because
there's no one else that understands me
like her and our breakup was pretty
amicable so i feel like there's still
something there between us
at the same time being friendzoned by a
woman i want to marry weighs on me daily
so i guess i'm looking for some advice
do i cut her off and move on am i
wasting my time being a simp thanks for
your time
this is a very like
not even straightforward but it was a
reasonable fan request i feel like
there's nothing
haywire about it yeah it's very uh
vanilla yeah in a good way exactly yeah
he's like he wants genuine just help
help yeah yeah just tell me there's
nothing funny about it yeah yeah the
love of my life is is moving on
help me yeah yeah yeah i'm with you yeah
yeah
there's nothing funny about it
um oh dear that's harsh man it's time
is
i'm tired of hearing bro i'm honest to
god like i i've been reading a lot of
messages recently from people the same
similar stuff it's just like
leave bro like leave like stop just stop
like people
i know emotions are hard to deal with
in terms of like you are when you're in
love you're convinced you're never
getting over it of course you're
literally convinced of course we've
never get an overview
and you all you you're also convinced
that you're the only one who's ever
experienced this level of pain
i mean
i felt pain before james i don't know
pain before oh i know you did you were
vomiting on my [ __ ] doorstep because
you drank yourself silly just just to
numb it
just to temporarily numb it you drank
yourself unconscious
i was wayward the next day oh i know
that's the first the only day i think i
called in sick for work oh really i've
never i never ever called in sick but
obviously um when i was working in
hospitality i remember specifically i
still like it on the market then yeah
you were [ __ ] it was a monday i'm
[ __ ] called in sick said i'm not
doing it god i'm not doing it not today
not today
yeah
you're convinced you're the only one
who's ever felt like this and every
single time
someone says bro trust me you'll get
over her yeah you want to punch her of
course you don't know what you're
talking about bro you've never felt this
yeah but everyone literally everyone has
and
literally every single time you get over
it and you get over it way faster than
you thought you would as well you think
okay i might get over it but it's going
to be like a year i can't live like this
for a year bro you're going to be over
in literally three weeks it if you cut
her off properly yeah but
it
depends on the circumstance because
when it happened to me it was different
i moved c
so for me it was it was tough but it was
literally a fresh start true but you can
also you
i feel like you can move city people i i
just feel like people aren't willing to
take the necessary steps yeah you can
move city without moving c yeah block
her [ __ ] like literally don't don't look
at her instagram don't look at her
twitter that's the worst [ __ ] yeah of
course it's checking her stories and
stuff and seeing when you see that story
pop up yeah and you think don't press it
don't press it don't press it don't you
leave half an hour you leave it you
leave it and then you check it and she
and all you see is her clinking clinking
boomerang yeah or in a car oh
night in the car at night passenger seat
passenger seat
fresh mercedes you already know what the
inside looks like
blacks out mercedes you're thinking
whose [ __ ] car is that yeah you're
shaking yeah you're shaking so you're
not you can't move on ladder yeah so fam
you literally need to cut her off
entirely and i literally feel like two
weeks in you'll you'll be fine you will
well i wouldn't say you'll be fine but
like you would have taken a step to be
like okay i can actually live my life
again yeah you'll have you'll be able to
within two weeks you will have days
where you you forget that you're even
grieving exactly or whatever it is
exactly you forget you just get you're
just you'll have a few days where you're
just getting on with your life i agree
and you're like oh i'm starting to feel
a little bit better actually and then
she will come back in your head and
stuff like that but if you just
completely cut her off if
it expedites the process but no one's
willing to do it true it's tough ma'am
yeah you've been with like you said
three years or three in a bit but she's
inviting you you ran the yard for easter
and stuff did you say yeah so he went to
his parents
parents um crib for easter don't invite
me for stuff like that
if you don't want me don't invite me to
your parents
you've got a next man and you're sucking
second next time you're saying bye to me
on the doorstep and you're going home
and doing anal with next man
don't you dare do that to me how do you
expect me to just get on with my life
because the parents like him that's
that's her problem if you want to move
on yeah then take the consequences yeah
yeah you can't have it both sides yeah
yeah yeah
you can't have it both sides
you've got to have one guy that you
bring through to keep the parents happy
yeah and then you're when your palm
wants to be happy you're using you're
using next man you can't have it both
ways if you want to lock me up and move
on then you have to deal with those
consequences as well and you have to
have those awkward discussions with your
mom and dad
[ __ ] you don't use me
well i'm here just hanging on
hanging on
grips
ah bro it's been there
we've all been in there i think every
human of asia has been there ah it's
tough man heartbreak is tough so um yeah
bro you're gonna have to let it go man
there's no there's no simping about you
just have to let her go and understand
the fact that she's moved on yes it's
been three years but if you actually
look at it in a grand scheme of things
you're what you said you're 25
soon to be 26 i'm assuming like you've
only lived 26 years of your life you
spent three years with her
in the blip of your whole life that's so
minuscule but because you're living
through it right now it feels like
eternity but in two years down the line
you probably wouldn't even remember the
heartbreak you were going through two
years ago 100 so just keep just keep
going bro
lock her off like jimmy said lock her
off but in
obviously i'm going to say not in a nice
way but or not in a bad way but you're
just gonna have to do what you have to
do you have to lock her off you have to
focus on yourself and just keep looking
forward and the more you do that they'll
like jimmy said there'll be a day you
just forget you're grieving i'm like oh
[ __ ]
i'm actually okay yeah man and i'm
actually okay i think a lot of people as
well make the mistake of
trying to
how do i explain it
trying to like start like luckily for
you when you moved to manchester um
around the time during your breakup you
had to move to manchester anyway and
yeah it wasn't i didn't move too many
because of them to get over here yeah
yeah
i feel like people make the mistake of
you know you say like focus on you
people make the mistake of i'm going to
make x y z changes to get over this
person which is like that's never going
to work because you're literally
every action you're doing it involves
her because yeah in a backwards way it
involves that person so just live don't
do anything different just live your
life even still where the [ __ ]
hoodies you got you just don't even
think about it just get on with it like
stuff like that like the whole rituals
of get deleting all the pictures and
getting rid of all the clothes and all
the gifts and all that stuff that's a
lot it's long bro and burning all the
little [ __ ] valentine's cards that
you kept just get on with your day and
just like just don't stop don't make
conscious efforts to try and forget
because that's just going to reinforce
the memory it's like literally saying
it's like don't think about elephants
this is like that's all you're going to
think about so don't don't worry about
stuff like that just get on with your
life and then just take it day by day by
day do not look at her social media it's
the worst possible thing because she's
going to be goading you bro
she's going to be posting stories and
checking to see if she's going to see if
you've looked and once you've looked
she's got she's happy she's she's going
to keep her job's done for the day yeah
her job is done for the day once you've
looked 100
so um yeah broski you're going to have
to lock off all tyres as tough as it's
going to be lock or full tires focus on
yourself look forward and just think
about your future bro yeah man
just keep doing [ __ ] you like yeah take
your mind off it yeah yeah
just find a distraction and before you
know it that distraction may become a
hobby and then before you know bum you
even forgot about her you're chilling
bro yeah yeah man it's the best way it's
tough but it's the best it's tough but
yeah like you said like three years
three is nothing three is there's
nothing it's nothing it's grand scheme
he's 25. he's 25 gonna be 26. so he's
only been an adult if he did go this way
he's literally only been an adult for
seven years seven years and for three of
those years so even he's only been an
adult for seven years and he was only in
that relationship
less than half of that
so he's like you're going to be an adult
from what like 18 to 80. let's say you
die at 80. so what's that like 72 years
32 years 72 years 32 years 62 years
sorry um yeah 62 years bro you're gonna
be an adult for and you've known her for
three you're gonna have gal in your life
do you know what you're gonna experience
in your life you're gonna experience so
much in your life she's a blip yeah she
unfortunately she is only gonna be a
blip and that's fine it's fine it's
literally just life bro you will get
over it she'll get over it you never
know you might even become friends at
the end of it and it's going to be
unamicable it's going to be very much
amicable so
that's just the best way to see it man
but like i said before because you're
living through it now
it seems like the end of the world you
know but it's literally only a blip man
yeah man it's literally best of luck g
literally best of luck um let us know
what pans out and yeah man yeah man i've
got a um a little something to talk
about uh hit me bro right so i see i
feel like i just need to explain
something to people okay because i
almost feel a little bit bad okay right
so
and this stem this stemmed up it
reminded me because i heard the other
day that um did you know this is kind of
trash newsie did you know that um
netflix have reported their first ever
drop in subscribers yeah two hundred
thousand they said they lost two hundred
thousand do you see the official stats
budget so there's something along the
lines of two hundred thousand
and i don't know if this is what you
were going to say but there also there
was also a rumor about how they want to
start winning ads on yeah yeah because
that's a thing is [ __ ] that yeah of
course but also of course it makes sense
because how else you could you're
literally you're actively losing money
the only way they make money from
subscribers that's literally the only
way they make money is from subscribers
so if you're actively making less money
every year now
like you have no choice but to put ads
on
that's a lot i think a lot more people
will drop off oh 100 percent they put
ads on there i think what they should be
focusing on i don't know what the
revenue is like but they i think that
what they should be focusing on
is um
[Music]
product placement in their netflix
originals
explain so
obviously they have netflix original
movies
if you've seen stuff like have you ever
seen there's a show called um
dark
the it's a three season three seasons
i've not seen it but i've seen it time
travel or something yeah yeah it's
[ __ ] shiny
it's a
it's
some kind of scandinavian yeah yeah it's
not english basically it's not english
they live in like iceland or something
like that i've seen like the first
episode but i've never really watched
anything juicy
i watched it a few years ago juicy
through yes
oh it's good
um but anyway but there
every car in that is a i want to say is
it an audi or a volvo
it's an audi okay every car in there is
an audi okay uh pretty much okay and it
just looks nice
um
and same with like i think is it
i wanna say potentially like
there's another film that's like that i
think it might be like girl with a
dragon tattoo or something like that
okay where there's bare volvos in there
okay and they look juicy okay um so
stuff like that like
you can have like sponsored movies
where you reach out to that whoever and
be like look
you will be the exclusive [ __ ] loads
of movies do it like this will be the
exclusive car of this netflix original
movie or this this exclusive drink of
this netflix original series will be
this
pay
yeah rather than ads
i'm not giving you money
for ads yeah it doesn't make sense i
think they should just drop the costs
and more people subscribe i don't think
they will though
of course they won't but that's that's
my that's my toppings um of course they
won what is it now seven nine nine nine
nine eight is that nine nine nine nine
ninety nine now they i think depending
on the thing you know the package and
how many screens and how many devices
have you used bag of screens so mine is
probably 9.99 mine's
that's a terrible business plan yeah
because you're not going to get any new
subscribers because the competition is
so [ __ ] high it is competition so i
pay for being personally and i know i'm
bougie with it netflix amazon prime
uh disney plus
now tv
crunchyroll
and i'm i'm contemplating apple tv as
well you need to go i know you said i
know you said i don't you need to get
apple tv bro
so i've got same as you i've got um
netflix i've got disney plus i've got
amazon prime i've got apple tv i've got
crunchyroll i've got um
i think that's it that's all that i've
got every and i've got sky above every
subscription
period yeah you know um
and the reason why i have that is
because i don't like adverts i hate it i
[ __ ] hate adverts yeah so if netflix
start doing that i'm i'm 100 coming off
100 i'm coming off and they're ashamed
they're not bringing in a fire they're
not they're not bringing enough they've
got the biggest catalogue but they're
not bringing fire yeah apple tv are
bringing fire bruh i say it week in week
out fair play i started invasion last
week i think i've got the finale left
it's good because you said you've only
seen the trailer before isn't it
last year
swear juicy so if i go on apple tv i've
got invasion to watch i've got several
differences severance finale
edge of your seat okay and you'll be
very from what i've heard ted lasso pops
as well you told me that as well yeah
there's there's movies on there there's
a um series with uh
samuel l jackson in there it's like i
can't remember what it's called the
lotta me of something i can't remember
his name i can't remember the name of
the show but i know it's good because
i've heard people tell me it's good all
right say let's all right apptv so i'm
gonna have i'm gonna have six
subscriptions apple tvs where it's
happening and i'm happy to do that but
yeah like
netflix because there's so much
competition netflix dropping their
prices never going to get themselves
yeah um so
i would say product placement is
unsponsored movies are way better than
ads because ads are going to just cause
people to [ __ ] off even more
they can't put ads on there and um i
will literally [ __ ] it off and they're
threatening to charge people for sharing
passwords and stuff like that really
yeah yeah i'm annoyed because my mom
uses my my mom uses mine so if i i can't
i'm annoyed because i won't be able to
cancel it because she watches she
physically watches my mom which is mine
all the time
but she's got her own like accounting
yeah yeah that's um that's annoying
she'll be annoyed as well i'll just pay
extra just charge me extra
what for no adverts yeah so no no not
even to be fair that's what they could
do they could do that no adverts maybe
13.99 don't do 30 19. i'm just saying
and
with adverts 99 yeah calm that's one way
of doing it another way of doing it also
is yeah with that sharing thing is yeah
this is like you can do unlimited
devices at this address
um
um
actually no because that wouldn't work
because devices counts as anything and
um you watch it on the train true sure
you said there's no yeah dress wouldn't
work um but yeah i guess just tvs there
maybe um tv because they can clock they
can clock addresses yeah and if you just
like right
we've they can figure out right like you
are definitely sharing your password
because you're watching it here
at this address and you're watching it
here yeah yeah so here's an email if you
want to keep doing this
then it's going to be you're going to
pay an extra two pound a month
or tell us which address you want us to
lock off because we're about to look off
now
tell us what you're dressed to lock up
because we're about to look
as we speak as we speak um
so yeah they can do it that way there's
a million things you can do but yeah
um ads is
a scary one yeah i'm i'm surprised
that's the first thing they came out
with
same i'm surprised because the whole
point of streaming services is no
[ __ ] adverts i know the whole point i
know but
the thing is they i wouldn't be
surprised if they'd done the maths
and they've probably sussed out that
we can lose well
it's not even probably they've
definitely suspect like if you just take
a look at like youtube and stuff like
that like
even if
50 of our subscriber base left because
you've got to think
they've got all these millions of
subscribers yeah but all those people
only pay a 10 or a month
[Music]
one advertising agency or whatever is
going to be paying way more than that so
it's like even i reckon even if let's
say they've got 10 million they've got
more but like let's say they've got 10
million subscribers
um
you can half that
and um
now you've got five million subscribers
plus ads so you've got five million
subscribers
watching roughly however much um and the
networks will be earning a set rate from
all these advertisers for every single
advert watched so even with half a
subscriber base if you if you put ads on
there you'll you'll triple your money
than what you they'll make more money
than they ever had
how do you think that ads will work do
you think that ads will work like they
do one like free trial crunchyroll where
they do ads in the middle of the shows
probably
i would lock off the whole time oh so
i'll lock off the whole time because
i've cause crunchyroll sporadically logs
me out sometimes oh is it but it doesn't
tell me it's logged me out oh so when
you go on it so it looks just normal
yeah yeah so i'll click play yeah advert
and then sometimes because i'm so used
to watching youtube i won't even realize
and i'll just keep going and then like
two minutes in advert and i'm like what
the [ __ ]
yeah and then another advert and i'm
like i was i'm not logged in and then
i'm like how does anyone watch free
control that is [ __ ] yeah all those
adverts it's way too many um so yeah 100
if netflix did it like that
i might i can stomach a pre-advert
yes
they do that on
amazon prime before you click anything
they show an advert of something else
yeah um
but yeah other than that i'm not yeah in
between yeah i'm not running it human
but yeah um they'll make money from
unskippable as well probably yeah
they'll make money on their brother
so it's a so it's they're probably
thinking look it's a leaking bucket as
it is
we can afford to lose 30 40 50
and still double our income if we add
ads or we can not add ads and keep
people happy but we're people that
haven't got us now and they're leaving
us anyway
so if they're going to leave we might as
well leave add ads and leave if you're
leaving yeah and whoever stays we can
make money from them right guys we're
going to take a quick break from the
episode to give a little shout to our
boys over at manscape guys so you
already know what mascara is all about
we talk about it every week alright guys
cool it's time to clear your holes and
smell the spring air with the weed
whacker okay we've spoke about the lawn
mower now it's time to hit the weed
whacker this is the nose and ear hair
trimmer
it provides propriet i can never say
this word proprietary
technology which helps which helps
prevent the nicks the crannies the snags
the tugs all up in them delicate holes
the delicate holes
yeah you gotta be careful with them
delicate oils of course pause um
after clearing your nose make sure you
get rid of that foul ball smell without
bro that foul ball smell with the crop
preserver and crop revive up okay so
we've got the preserver which is an
anti-chafing ball deodorant and
moisturizer and the reviver is a spray
on toner for your balls okay
that's it
that is it
all you need to do guys is head on over
to manscape.com use the code sng sierra
november golf
and um
one more time from the top manscape.com
code is sng sierra november gold thank
you sir that's going to get you 20 off
and free shipping worldwide 20 are free
shipping worldwide
join four million men jump on the
bandwagon guys manscape.com let's get
back to the episode
but at the same time bro it's a it's a
dodgy one it is ah problem adverse
anyway we'll see what happens we'll see
what happens but luckily luckily now
we're at a point where there's so many
other streaming services
that
there's the competition is there you
know so if if people are sprung on
netflix because netflix was probably the
original one oh it was the og it was the
og everyone had or has netflix you know
now people got options there you go so
um but anyway this is such a tangent
from what i actually was originally
talking about um
i feel bad because you know the other
week when i was singing about trolls
yes
i feel like people not got the wrong end
of the stick
but if you've been here for a while you
know your boy gets excited about stuff
yeah so trolls world tour banks yeah but
it's still a trolls movie
meaning meaning
it's [ __ ] trolls like it's not
schindler's list do you know that i mean
it's not it's not a nostalgic thing
it's a troll
yeah it's banging
for a trolls movie yeah it's like if i
said to you bro have you seen the new
wodison grommet is that it actually
slaps to be fair it actually says you
know it slaps in the in the universe of
wallace
not slaps as a movie yeah yeah yeah it's
not exceeded
like movies in general i mean somehow
this wallace and gromit movie has broken
free of the wallace's comic brand and
it's just an amazing movie yeah well so
when i was singing about uh trolls world
tour being a movie it's a movie as far
as trolls movies go okay in my opinion
okay so since i'm singing about it i've
had so many dms so many videos so many
people like i'm watching trollsworld
tour because of this and i have bad
people come back like yo that movie [ __ ]
yeah it's a trolls movie yeah
it's also a trolls movie they forget
yeah relax yeah relax
but because i feel bad i've got a little
saturn else that i want to say all right
so scrap trolls world tour yeah if you
don't like trolls then just don't watch
it but i watch a lot of i watch
everything so as far as trolls movies
goes i thought that's a banging trolls
movie
what's a movie movie just in general
turning red on disney plus turning red
is that animated oh yeah oh is it oh
yeah you've never even heard of it bro
it's a new okay
it's a movie bro and i know i said this
about it's amazing
as far as movies go okay
it's a movie bro granted it's still a
kids movie turning red so it's about um
keep talking i put myself a juice cool
yeah uh turning red
um
yeah turning red bro so basically it was
heavy
did you put more thing in there jd yeah
did you yeah jd was about like here
yeah
and i thought i was a fair play it just
tastes more aptly okay all right apple
jd and apple juice is wow oh that's it's
the it's a wave my boy ivy told me about
it oh you know i beat you yeah yeah yeah
either way yeah it just tastes like
apple juice this oh it's a silent
assassin
it's a silent assassin wow that's crazy
um anyway turning red
so it is a disney movie animated disney
movie about a young girl it's like a
coming of age
but i'm just oh
indian or yeah okay cool try to
visualize it um so yeah
i think it's chinese um but anyway so
typical asian family honor thy parents
super like well-studied well-mannered
young girl she's like 13.
um
and
her family have this like without
spoiling it too much i'm trying to think
of like ways i can describe it that they
would show me the trailer so her family
have this like
way of they basically have this curse
gift stroke curse
that
when they become a certain age
when they they
have the ability to transform into a red
panda
okay like a big red panda okay and that
comes with like the strength and the
traits of what being a [ __ ] massive
bear would would give you but anyway
it's uncontrollable you don't you can't
decide when you you have to train
yourself to be able to transform back
and forth
okay like some titan type thing yeah so
you can like literally like a titan so
if she gets too excited this is like
it's based on your emotions if you get
angry or excited or whatever you turn
into the panda okay um so
the whole movie is about her trying to
like keep this under control and they
see it as such a curse that they have a
ritual of how to get rid of it okay um
but it's only on a certain day so it's
basically the whole movie they try and
get rid of it it has to be on like this
red moon ritual on the red moon which
only happens like once a month or
whatever and you have to catch it that
night okay and it happens to every woman
in her family okay and has done for
generations okay and basically they seal
the spirit of the panda in this like
jewelry or whatever anyway so the whole
movie is about her discovering this
curse
and trying to
manage it
from the day she discovers it up until
the day she can get rid of it and like
it's just like your tip is literally
your typical coming of age movie and it
is very it it translates very well into
what it is
like not like i would know but what i
can imagine it's like hitting puberty
and i like the way they've kind of
premised it as in like turning into the
big word panda is basically a heat in
your period okay
um and it's like they even have like
little nuances there like where the
mom's like did the red happen like has
the red happened and
the mom's not talking about the panda
thing oh she's talking about the period
okay but the girl's like yeah the red
hat like what the [ __ ] is this um so
anyway it's like it is a very very good
like very
strong well-written
um funny witty
coming-of-age like teenage movie okay
it's great and the animation
is very anime as well oh is it yes it is
okay
yes it is that's what makes it better
okay they have like very subtle the best
thing i can describe it or compare it to
i don't think you've seen it is scott
pilgrim versus the world i have seen
that gang
so you know how scott pilgrim versus
where there's not even an animated yeah
they'll have a very comic bookie
scenes in like the coins and bloods yeah
yeah yeah of course that's exactly
exactly like that it's exactly like that
it's great even as a so [ __ ] what
everyone thought about trolls
get over yourself
turning red is [ __ ] fantastic plus
yeah disney plus sales it's
[ __ ] fantastic okay i've seen it
three times
it only came out a few weeks ago see it
three times okay it's great
man said tony the tiger it's great it's
great bro i swear down
turning red is a buff movie okay so this
is my apology like i i don't like to get
put all my like uh all my [ __ ] on the
table yeah i like to keep something for
myself sometimes but turning red i'll
give you man that because i know a lot
of men were pissed off like how's james
out here yeah i like i love when he
recommends this and that but he's
talking about trolls i've watched it
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i'm like yeah
it's charles what did you expect
um i was just gasped yeah but turning
red is actually [ __ ] solid cool i've
got a recommendation for you which
people are probably which people have
definitely sent it to us on our socials
but i don't know if they send it to you
scandal of the anatomy watched it
watched it
juicy it's juicy
but i'm also on the fence oh about what
you've seen the whole thing i've seen
the whole thing same
i have a theory about it
but it's going to be spotted so
you guys are just going to have to skip
ahead yeah sorry guys i'll make sure
that after we speak about this the next
cause i always do like the time stamps
of the chapters of the show as soon as
we finish this the the next thing will
next chapter so skip to the next chapter
if you don't want to know spoilers about
having an emmy of a scandal yeah because
i need to give my theory of a scandal a
scandal of the anatomy or whatever it is
and you're laughing at me
[Laughter]
[ __ ] it out because every time i hear
anatomy i think grayson at me straight
away i know what you mean straight up
okay yeah yeah and that move scandal so
obviously the premise of the show
i'm not even going to give contact to
people that want to watch it because i'm
just going to spoil it anyway so so you
see how
obviously the premise is politician
has an affair
she accuses him of rape
and it's very the the main crux of the
show is basically
the ambiguity and the gray area between
what was consent and what wasn't we're
not saying that you there's no issue
with you dragging her in the lift
pinning her by a throat tearing off the
clothes we don't give a [ __ ] about that
we just need to understand that not only
was she consenting
she can say she wasn't consenting to the
cows come home but the issue that we
want to address is
did you understand that that's what she
was doing
which i really enjoyed that
but
i feel like with the way that they
premise the plot twists
i feel like
they in my um the way i imagine it is
that like they've created this really
well paced really well well-written
show about the gray area of consent and
then when it was time to pull the
trigger the pr team was like we can't
have a show that talks about the gray
area of consent why do you think that
because because it's not good press to
talk about like you're not allowed to
say there's a gray area in consent no
i'm not i'm not talking about that i'm
talking about why do you think about
that in the show oh what made me think
about that was because the twists in my
head were [ __ ]
for example so
if i think about the things that i
enjoyed most about that show
was
kind of as you go you're not under it's
very hard to
understand is like
does he think he raped her and he's just
lying about it because they premise him
as this really really good liar of
course and is he just lying to everyone
and is he just like a master manipulator
yeah and he definitely raped her and all
this stuff
and it slowly transitions to
did he rape her but also doesn't know
that he raped her because like corner of
prick tease and all this stuff like in
his head is he just jokingly being like
she wants it she wants it yeah like you
see so
narcissistic that he genuinely thinks
that like everyone wants to [ __ ] and
there's no way and there's no way she's
saying no um especially because that him
and her especially had like a lot of
risky sex and then when they did the
flashback to the one at uni
like berry with holly berry
she said no
initially and then he calmed it down a
bit and then she was down is this better
and then in his head is he convinced
yeah that she actually wants to say yes
now yeah so
my favorite parts of that whole show
were like ra
i don't think this guy knows he's raping
people you start off thinking oh he's a
rapist yeah as soon as you see like
olivia like crying and she called me
he called me a prick tease and all that
stuff you're like oh he's a rapist he's
100 rapists
but then you start getting into his
psyche a little bit and seeing what a
narcissist he is and what god complex he
has you think i don't think this guy
knows he's raped
because
when
they um came to the final conviction at
the end i wouldn't say i wouldn't spoil
it but um when he came home to the with
the misses and she said did you say it
did you say it yeah and he's like yeah
but i don't know he didn't say that he
said what do you think i said oh when he
said that because he was stern yeah yeah
across the room what do you think i said
and he said she said something along the
lines of i think she said i think you
said it because that sounds like
something you would say and then he said
something i can't remember what he said
he said it and then just walked off well
the conversation was good he said i yes
i said it
but it was all part of the game that we
had
in terms of that consensual non-consent
um
but
that's
all of that if you take all of that
i genuinely believe
it would have been the perfect show
because it it really does dive into like
these are real cases that really happen
yeah yeah yeah and there's real like uh
rape cases that happen in terms of some
of them are like when you look at it
from like an outside lens you're like
how can you be done for rape for that
and there's other ones that you're like
bro how can you not know that that's a
rape like what are you doing it says all
these things and is he lying or does he
genuinely doesn't think he's right
people or is she lying and none of these
things actually happened and all this
stuff which i found was just fantastic
and very nuanced and like very
thought-provoking and just really well
written and i feel like
the stuff about spoiler alert if you
still didn't listen to my previous
warning this is the spoiler alert when
they did the twist of
turns out that she's holly the
prosecutor is holly and she knows you're
a rapist because she was the one that's
raped like
that if you actually think about the
story that twist is completely
irrelevant to the story why
because
there's two massive plot falls in this
that really annoyed me which i feel like
ruined it which i which which made me
feel like they needed this to distract
us
from the concept that consent might be a
gray area okay because it's very
non-woke to say consensual area
so
if you think about it
the whole holly story came up was
because a third third-party
administrator
complained and then they start digging
up this holly stuff
and that's when his wife gets invested
in the holy stuff
the prosecutor uh mary whatever her name
is kate kate wood
woodstock
herbie and holly
she doesn't use any of her holly
knowledge
to help the conviction
she doesn't use any of her holly
knowledge to spread or to get anything
she can't exactly she can't so the twist
is it relevant in terms of
oh
kate is actually holly so we know that
he raped holly because holly is kate and
she knows what really happened
whether she's holly or not the turn of
events and the inclusion of the
inclusion of holly into the story is
still relevant because of what it does
for the wife
so whether kate's holly or not
yes it's a twist but in terms of how the
story develops is still irrelevant i
disagree bro
why do you disagree because what do you
think we learnt from holly being k or
what do you think it brought to the
story well it brought a lot of
dynamic in the actual um
in actual court it felt like suits like
a suits type thing yeah it felt like
suits but what i'm saying is is like it
it brought a nice dynamic but i also
feel we could have got that same dynamic
if kate was just a victim of assault
herself as opposed to from my man yes if
she was a victim of assault herself of
course of course it would have been the
exact same tenacity i don't think would
have brought exactly the same because
it's
yes it's personal regardless because she
has been through it but it's even more
personal because one she's prosecuted or
she's trying to prosecute the person
that's raped someone else even though
she can't get caught knowing that this
is the guy that's raped me because it
will it will [ __ ] up her job
all of that is
and as well because holly and um i can't
remember the wife's name
sophie holly and sophie were girls back
in the day in uni as well so i feel like
that twist was necessary yeah especially
for like you said it brought out a lot
more for the wife and her dynamic that
relationship yeah was
wild yeah exactly
that's that's what i thought that's
that's my point that's what i thought
brought to the story the holy stuff
got the wife
invigorated of course i was like i'm not
[ __ ] dropping this of course holly
was my boy i'm not drunk that was the
point of it exactly but that
holly being bought into it invigorating
the wife and how the wife because the
wife what the wife did with that
information
even though she ended up confronting
kate at the end
it didn't matter to the case the holly
information mattered to the case but the
fact that holly was kate didn't matter
to the case when she clocked it was her
nothing it didn't matter it didn't look
like it didn't matter the twist didn't
matter to the story it mattered because
there's no way in hell neither of them
can say that
oh this is holly you're not k blah blah
how do you know because x y and z he
raped like he would be he'll be in
double jeopardy by announcing the fact
that he knows that kate is holly
because how else would he know but he
didn't know he thought he he thought she
was familiar but he didn't know even at
the end of the show he didn't know that
kate is holly sophie knew but he did he
never knew or he hadn't i can understand
an intuition he had an intuition but
they didn't develop on it which is what
i'm saying in terms of like it makes me
feel like this was a last minute twist
i'm not saying that you can't have that
twist but i'm saying they didn't utilize
that twist which makes me feel like it
wasn't supposed to ever be there because
it was in all other aspects a very well
written show i can understand if it was
a poorly written show and that was the
twist then i'm like okay that was just a
show but in
my opinion all other aspects of that
show were very well written very well
sequenced very well paced um and very
well nuanced
but that twist
because it didn't
bring that because you the
what i'm saying is like the way the
story ends because what
when you're doing like screen writing
the twist is supposed to be the last
jigsaw
in terms of that when you bring a
dramatic twist it's supposed to bring up
[ __ ] that's crazy but now that i know
that all this makes sense but that twist
doesn't do that
it's just a twist oh i'm holly
but you being holly doesn't change
anything else that we know up until now
it doesn't change anything else because
you're i can find out i can imagine if
she said oh i'm holly or we found out
she's holly and it wasn't actually the
administrator that sent that
like anonymous thing it was her it was
actually her
then we're like ah okay
so that's how we know this and this is
how
herby and holly matters because she's
now planting she can't say it but she's
planting seeds yeah so that we can find
out like if she was planting evidence
here and there and jeopardizing her
career but she knows if this actually
comes out then he's going to get
convicted because she knows she's a
rapist then that twist makes sense but
because she was so against anyone
finding out that she's holly even him
even sophie she didn't plant any
evidence she wasn't the one that told
anyone that holly was involved so the
whole holly aspect to the
as far as kate's concerned the whole
holly aspect to the story doesn't matter
to kate so the fact that kate is holly
is irrelevant it kate could have been
holly holly could have been kate's
sister holly could have been kate's um
long lost cousin like
it doesn't matter like it doesn't
because she didn't utilize that aspect
as far as the continuity of the story i
understand it brings invigoration and it
brings like suspense and like you think
is she going to be able to keep it
together because she's like got ptsd and
she's fumbling her words yes it brings
excitement but as far as what i consider
a
good plot twist i need to know what this
plot twist has to do with the story and
as far as the story from beginning to
end her being holly
is a side story
it doesn't it doesn't the story from
beginning to end is exactly the same
whether she's holly or not
whereas if you if you if you look at
something like [ __ ] like if you look
like classic films or plot twists like
usual suspects have you ever seen usual
suspects like kaiser associates so
there's like the typical that's like the
typical like
uh um it's a story kevin spacey is like
a very small time they're trying to
basically bust this like huge crime lord
who's basically like the boogeyman in
terms of crime and they they're
interviewing this very very very small
like player in this massive mob
organization okay and he's was being
interviewed he basically tells the whole
story so the whole story of the usual
suspects is through his lens and it's
all narrated by him
and at the very end you find out that
kevin spacey
is the boss that they're talking about
and the whole story he made up was that
but it connects all the dots same with
like um i don't even know if you'd saw
it when we saw it like um when i said
about um
the sixth sense
where bruce willis is actually dead yeah
yeah yeah like bruce what is being dead
makes [ __ ] sense when you look back
at the whole story it makes that twist
oh [ __ ] you've answered so many
questions that makes [ __ ] sense okay
so it's kind of like it's a tangent to
the story so it's tangent to the part of
the story but it's like a branch yeah so
i understand what you mean because it's
a very and that's the thing is like it's
not a small twist it's [ __ ] massive
so in my head i'm like why would you
bring in such a huge twist
if you're not gonna allow it to be the
jigsaw so what i'm saying is like if you
take away that if you take away the
holly thing
then the premise of the show
is all about
the gray area of consensus
did he rape her did he know he raped her
is she lying like that's what the whole
thing is about and this holly thing is a
side story that doesn't go anywhere or
interject and it doesn't it doesn't
matter to the main story it's
interesting yeah but it doesn't matter
to the main story i think so it's going
off i think um
now i understand where you're coming
from but i also think
budgeting had a lot to do with it
because this this was a limited series
only six episodes that's rare
granted that's rare it's usually eight
to ten on most limited series like
netflix produced so
maybe they just didn't have enough
budget uh maybe i mean put that in there
and make sure it patterns well and blah
blah blah because obviously the way it
ended you know the way it ended that was
my second that was my second frustration
yeah that was a that was a poor ending
yeah in terms of like
they just didn't okay considering like
the whole show is about like we're in
court and we're talking about this is
what we need for a conviction and this
is the evidence required and we need to
understand that this was this is all
very specific in the code of law
yet the way we end it
is
his wife
spills a little story about something
that happened 20 years ago with zero
evidence no written evidence no fact
like no no physical evidence no evidence
whatsoever all she has to do is ring the
police and say oh 20 years ago my
husband threw away a tin full hat of
[ __ ] heroine that heroine was snorted
by a guy that killed himself and all of
a sudden the [ __ ] prime minister
the prime minister and an mp are going
to pen for it
with with what evidence
it was a poor ending poor ending it
wasn't and she had motive to lie because
your husband's just been on trial for
rape yeah it was rushed it was a rushed
ending that's why that's what i'm saying
six episodes fair it could have been one
of them ones where they had to condense
quite a few things chop up a few things
and be like you ain't got a budget for
it so this is how it's going to end and
the middle bit with the lim i was going
to say lucy the cake with them maybe
maybe or holly yeah maybe yeah that's
the way i see it maybe but without with
that argument it would make more sense
to just not do that all together i know
but it still added a lot of elements
drama he had a drama to the sort of
series as a whole it had a drama series
yeah it did it did but overall it's good
it is good very good limited series i
really enjoy english based series i
thoroughly enjoy them sometimes i really
do as well they're just
they really are good they are good they
are they really are good sometimes so
yeah anatomy of a scandal is actually
good it is good um
but yeah you've got uh trash news now
i do have a trash news right bear with
me yeah
this is the
this is the heading i'm gonna read in a
second
gay baboon
terrorizes villagers in south africa and
rapes five men
what
men at a village in the northwest are
leaving in fear over a male a big male
baboon that likes to grope and honk
human males the baboon is said to have
attacked more than six men in the past
week and what's baffling and what's
baffling the villagers is the fact that
baboon only attacks guys and does not
hurt it doesn't hurt its victims but
rather performs sexual acts on top of
them
on top of the terrified victim and
leaves one and leaves oh [ __ ] it out
because it's a it's a [ __ ] i was old
newspaper it's an old newspaper i can't
even see the punctuation
one victim george said he was coming
from the local shebene when the baboon
attacked him and pinned him down
i thought he wanted to kill me but
realize it was after my bum
george said five men were admitted to
hospital after experiencing acute anal
pains and fatigue not fatigue
doctors confirmed the men had anal
cancer
the baboon was the baboon which has now
been nicknamed
samizi
travels alone
and this according to um animal
behaviors special is a specialist sorry
it's a strange occurrence because
baboons are known to travel in groups
a specialist lizzie mckenzie said the
baboon might be an outcast and chased
away by its troop that is why it travels
alone but as [ __ ] i can't even see
the thing
but as as to the reason it's attacking
males only it beats me i've never seen
the behavior in my 20s in this field
blah blah blah when the journalists
visited the village all male school kids
were said to be wearing dresses as a
preventative measure
until the baboon was dealt with oh my
god
bro oh my god a baboon terrorizes
villages in south africa and rapes five
men
i promise you thoughts i'll i'll scream
and cry and beg him i know he can't
understand me beg him please don't i'd
rather him kill me fam you're coming
home from work one day you've just left
the shop you're in south africa you just
left the shop you're going home you
bought some milk and some [ __ ] for the
yard you're walking home you've got your
headphones you see you can't you're
distorted you're distorted you're your
headphones in you're chilling you don't
even know waguan all of a sudden you see
you you see people screaming but you
can't hear you don't even know what guan
and you just look back you see the
baboon coming at you
coming at you bro oh because there's bag
of gal around you and he sees you in
shorts shorts on a t knows you're a guy
he sees your quads and knows you're a
guy oh god he's galloping off everyone's
saying run it's the baboon run
but you've got your headphones in with
your milk skipping home
fam it jumps
you look back as you're looking back you
see it in the air like a fun naruto type
thing it pins you down bro what do you
do i just told you what i'd do
scream for help
because if he's draping up my shorts
i don't think anyone has the power to
hold me down
do you really understand what i mean by
that the funny thing is i do yeah the
funny thing is i [ __ ] do i i don't
want to like i don't want to diminish
anyone that's been raped because that's
obviously that's yeah no yeah
but i don't think 10 men have the power
to hold me down in that position because
the adrenaline that'll be going from our
body i'm facing up yeah one way or
another i'm getting my back to the
ground to the ground
that's what i'll be thinking about if he
starts yanking up my shorts i'm getting
my back to the ground
kill me from then
kill me like a man i said i'm mean help
me everyone someone better help me
everyone someone better help me because
if he's just out here raping man and
dipping
i'm sending for anyone who was there
on some punisher thing
i'm a vigilante now i'm an auntie here
john bernthal yeah yeah i'm an anti-hero
yeah i'm feeling a punish anyone who
witnessed that and didn't help
i'll go on a killing spree throughout
bro i couldn't experience that anal
cancer
yeah what do you mean cancer well
because you got banged by a monkey
you've got cancer now i don't know bro
that's like that doesn't make sense
show me the science books that show that
they're relevant as soon as you said
counsel i want to pause you but i
thought let me just let him get it
doesn't make sense doesn't make sense
the fatigues all of them went in there
with anal cancer
what genes has he got we need to
research he's got science yeah he's got
side and he's dashing it out yeah that's
not making sense um but anyway we're on
the time frame so let's finish off with
twitter hall of fame
right guys another week
another 12 hall of fame
my boyfriend invited me to his girl's
birthday on the weekend i said
are his friends buff
my man kissed his teeth and said yeah
man my girl's the ugliest one i nearly
flipped the car
ah
my girl's the ugliest one
shank in a twist
my dad definitely went for looks my
mom's food deserves to be on fear factor
that's [ __ ] funny wow that's jokes
first sight of self-love exists is
accepting your hairline
fam
i love my hairline as it is but as soon
as if it starts to peel back go back i
promise you now if i can well and truly
accept it
oh i love myself it might me i think
i'll need to do six months in tibet yeah
to really get down to grips because you
need to do something
this is a two part so this is a tweet
and a coin tweet
so the main tweet says i'm so
unimpressed by men who just want to [ __ ]
i left my [ __ ] at home now what quote
how far do you live
[Laughter]
[ __ ] it out that's funny
um if i was rihanna you guys want me
again any you guys want me getting any
[ __ ] from me no album no baby pics
nothing
facts facts facts
him
why are you sucking me like why are you
sucking me like this her
i need my hair done on friday
i swear
it's like that raw why are you sucking
me like this i don't even need my hair
money i need money money [ __ ] i'll let
her crack on
i'll let it crack on fair [ __ ] play
crack on
i eat my first meal of the day at 5 pm
bro don't ask me for no advice
yo
that's funny
him
i don't have no reason to lie her
exactly you lie for no reason
white [ __ ] see their ops and be like
we got company
that's jokes
this one just one off we're married in
my head so i don't care oh
cracked
this is actual facts i know the last day
on earth is gonna be so much fun on
twitter oh
isn't it just it's gonna be juicy on
twitter bro rags once i squirt on you
you're my property
fair
fam
fair
fair before i have sex i go to the
bathroom talk to myself throw up some
gang signs and walk out
there was a reply to this
remember seeing a deaf person getting
jumped because they were thought because
they thought they were throwing up gang
signs and then reply to that imagine
getting fingered by a deaf person i want
him to talk [ __ ] in there
wild role that conversation went left
twitter has no
filter no boundaries
this is a question so gospel songs are
just diss tracks for satan
facts
came to college happy and motivated now
i'm leaving mentally ill
happens jesus
my homie begged me to let him borrow my
crib so he could slide a shorty over i
finally said all right
why this [ __ ] walked through the door
with her and said to me
damn you still at my house sure he
started laughing at me [ __ ] always
want to show off i just left
that's something i would do to you i
know you that's what i'm going to do
please bro i've got nowhere else please
you'd agree and then i would mug you up
oh my god
i'm sorry
this man calling me to tell me the
cologne i got him is getting him mad
compliments i'll throw that [ __ ] away
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] it out move seats on the train
so an elderly white couple could sit
together and another white guy came to
tell me that was so sweet so glad you're
not a slave anymore eternal rock of ages
huh
fam
fam what
i wouldn't know how to react brother
that would catch man off guard
so i'm not a slave anymore
my girlfriend's best friend told me you
might not be in the wedding but i will
i've never been put in my place harder
that's a fact bro
fair
i've never been put in my place harder
one girl just beeped a horn and screamed
always sexy at me
i've lost all sense of masculinity bro
that's happened to me before that's
happened i've had the oil i've had it
now while you're walking my knees went
in
yeah my knees went in and i grabbed my
imaginary bag
for a protection
[ __ ] oh i was in sword ah i was in
shoreditch one i was in shoreditch one
girl called me over to her car to get my
details i've never felt so masculine in
my life same same
okay this is um this is a conversation
quotations this [ __ ] put you to sleep
huh
[ __ ] it was 4am
rags
shut up someone replied women love to
take credit
and then the same bread of reply to that
quotation this [ __ ] had you silent oh
what is in there to talk about this
later
women love to take credit with their
favorite fam they do they actually do
oh
don't text me at night because they ate
me texting you back it's the demons
it's always you up and never you are the
bane of my existence and the object of
all my desires
that's from [ __ ] bridget and i see on
twitter all the time
[ __ ] that's fine right run me one more
fam one more one more i've got two more
actually two more go go this heat made
me realize i won't survive hell i've got
to change
i've got a change fair play um
and there was one that everyone sent me
i've got it on here
uh something to do with you ah
facetimed her and someone whispered eew
that's him
thing is
women will actually do that as well they
will they'll actually do that with chest
with chest
eew that's him ew whilst you're still
there just can't see you just
look nah oh that's him is that him
oh sorry i didn't know you oh sorry
you're not muted can you hear
you're just there looking at the screen
like from
hang on
i'm done
oh is that him
[ __ ] no your mom
anyway guys that was a fun monday that
was i laughed a lot more than i thought
i was going to so thank you for that um
as always guys head on over to
patreon.com we'll see you on thursday
love love
[Music]
you